i think lux's a huge part of success
luck does not play
a part at all don't you dare try to make
me feel
bad about what i have accomplished in
life
[Music]
i was voted most likely to succeed in
high school in the year 2014.
in 2003 in 1994
i always had my homework done on time i
worked harder than the other students
around me
editor-in-chief of the school newspaper
i was president of the national honor
society so
i had to learn english at the same time
of doing my studies
i took extra morning courses take home
courses
and i wanted to finish within three
years which i did
i went to a public high school in
central jersey it was just kind of that
typical
suburban americana high school kind of
experience
going to a private school a lot of the
kids were almost like what you would see
in gossip girl you know super posh and i
was one
of 15 to 20 black kids in the entire
school you know my mom actually ended up
working a second job just to send me
there
when i first came to this country and i
saw the
high school i knew i needed to get out
of there
every friday there was a fight
the graduation rate was about 11
i work as an event planner in new york
city i'm a tv host
i am the ceo of electronic components
company
i do believe i am the most successful
person in my class
i don't talk to many people from my high
school but i would say
given my hand and given my age i'm
probably the most successful when i
purchased my home
i was 23 being able to put that down
payment not only made me feel proud but
i knew it made other people that look
like me proud
and it set me up for you know the next
few years i think a lot of people think
i'm the most successful because i'm
probably the most
well-known or the most famous i
personally don't
feel that way because there's people i
graduated with that are doctors or
lawyers they're like curing disease
they're fighting in the military they're
raising families they're giving
something to
society and i just talk on camera
i think lux's a huge part of success
there are so many
things that come to you in life that are
completely beyond your control so here's
an example my first ever job that i got
out of college
i was at a job fair and i was there all
weekend and i got
lots of auditions and interviews and no
offers the very last day
i went to the bathroom at the convention
center before i went back to my hotel
and i bumped into a guy there who was
wearing a shirt with a logo i didn't
recognize i struck up a conversation
turns out he had a friend who wasn't
there but that was hiring for a job
put me in touch i interviewed a week
later and got my first job ever
but for me that that was luck in my mind
because what if i
had drank one less bottle of water that
day i didn't have to go to the bathroom
what if i had decided hey i'm going to
go back to the bathroom at my hotel room
luck does not play a part at all as soon
as you
choose to get up that day
you are paving your path you're choosing
to use something instead of just not
doing anything
and more things happen but if you just
choose to
feel sorry for yourself and say ah you
know what the first three days i didn't
get any job offers i'm not going to go
back
but you went back i think that if you
get up you get out of bed every day you
have a chance of being successful
but i think race gender the
situation you're born into plays a huge
part into it you could work just as hard
as me
and probably be more talented than i am
but maybe you just didn't get that one
opportunity or you didn't get that one
luck or you didn't get the chance to
take that unpaid internship because you
had to work all summer you know i think
that it
plays a huge part into it sometimes
being a black woman you don't want to
come across as crazy black women right
or even in the office like
you have to make sure how you present
yourself and how you speak you know and
people are always looking at
the way you carry yourself and growing
up my parents always said you know the
minute you enter the room people are
going to be staring at you the entire
time whether you see
it or not but they're going to be
looking at you through a microscope
being a woman and being in spanish
plays a lot in this world i have to work
double for them to be able to take me
seriously
i've always been realistic my reality
was that i was in the bronx
about 56 of the population back then of
the women get pregnant very early
as i was going to high school the first
thing i saw was this girl
she had her child caring everything and
carrying all the stuff and putting on
the bus i at that moment i said
i'm not going to be in the statistics
but i had to actually just
do everything and anything to get out of
there it is not
fair but at least i accepted the the
challenge let's say
that is what you make how hard do you
work
how much do you want it uh one person
had said to me
in front of everybody in my office and
she said to me you think you're better
than everybody else
i threw it back at her i said yes i am
better i'm better because i make myself
better i'm proud that i came up from the
bronx i'm proud that i was
really poor and i thought don't you dare
try to make me feel
bad about what i have accomplished in
life if any millionaire want to use my
story
have at it maybe what inspires all the
people to say you know what
opportunity is there what are you going
to do to get that opportunity
i do think that if you don't have
success it doesn't mean that you didn't
want it
i think that maybe you just didn't have
the right opportunities or the right
information to get you to where
you wanted to be or you didn't have that
one cheerleader that one person kind of
cheering you along or supporting you so
you could take
you know this opportunity to land you to
here what about the other minorities or
even anyone of any race that
you know wants to get that dream job
working for the big company or the big
bank but didn't have the chance to go to
school
right or wants to be able to take this
opportunity to go to this job fair after
school but they have to take care of you
know their kids or you know their
siblings or whatnot
so i do think everyone has a chance of
being successful but it's other factors
outside that limit you from being able
to go where you want to go
because it's definitely inspirational
and motivational your story i totally
agree
but do you feel it's still typical i
think it's a big problem in this country
that you point at one successful example
of something and say
all the problems are fixed like look
they could do it or if this is what
happens
when sometimes that's the exception that
proves the rule
and i think that's a little bit
exploitative because there are a lot of
problems that you know one person who's
successful
doesn't mean that they're all fixed yeah
um
even when i am that story i would have
an issue
as well too with them using that as a
blanket statement
the way that i was able to get it done
also too by having a work mom by my mom
being able to work by me not
actually having to do a lot of the
simple things
these people who are saying oh well i
did it when i was your age i
you know worked the job and was able to
afford a house and a car and pay off
college yeah well college only costs
like eight thousand dollars in and it's
costing
fifty eight thousand dollars a year now
and i think
for younger people and people from
minorities and from marginalized groups
that don't have the infrastructure
to have either scholarships or have
money
family money to pay for these things or
to help out that's something that
i think a lot of people don't realize if
they're not in that situation that
that's the reality for a lot of people
you know i don't think high school
should have superlatives i think it puts
everybody in a bucket
and you know kind of puts those labels
on you i don't see the point in them
it could be bad or it could be good
getting told when you're 18 that you're
most likely to succeed out of the
hundreds of
other kids your age that's terrifying
and i started to think what do i have to
do to live up to that building and live
up to all these expectations people had
of me it is a pressure that you
have to just always be there be the best
not on the other hand it pushes you i
think school should put more of a focus
on finding your passion and not
necessarily finding a job that
pays the bills you know you don't have
to be a lawyer or a doctor or a banker
to make
good money you know as long as you can
find something you're passionate about
and you have the hard work
you could do any job do what makes you
happy and everything else will fall into
place
[Music]
you